how do you start learning a language
from scratch and why is the starting
phase such a delicate process in the
overall language learning process I mean
your approach if I understood you
correctly it's the following you are
having the native text right and you're
still an absolute beginner and you're
trying to translate the native text into
your into your own language into Italian
yes yes I have to target I have actually
bilingual resource meaning I have the
text in say German the target language
that I'm learning and I have it in
Italian so that I can compare the two
systems and then I do this back and
forth translation so I make sure that I
first I understand it and then I absorb
it so to answer your question how do I
learn a language from scratch my I have
to say that my strategy hasn't changed
that much in the course of years but it
has I refined it so first of all I use
this technique meaning that you know if
somebody asked me how do you how do you
learn a language from scratch first of
all my piece of advice my first piece of
advice would be get hold of a language
series that you like on the market now
whatever important thing to say is that
the language series that you use is
important obviously because you know if
you like the material it's it's it's a
plus but I also have to add that you
have to learn how to use it because
books like the books that you see here
for example they're they're books in
there pieces of something but you have
to absorb the content if you want them
to be useful because books were written
for you to not only to understand them
some books were written for not only to
enjoy them like romances but also to
help you acquire an ability like a
manual so first of all learn how to
choose material and I'm just not talking
about searching on the internet but also
if you go to a library you leave through
a book and you see if you like it
visually for example this is one of the
very first things that meets the eye as
I say and then obviously you have to
learn how you have to figure out the
best way to use it to make the best out
of it so this is the very first step
that I take and the second step and this
is like a refinement that happened in
the last five years is that I find
myself
partner as soon as possible right so you
know the search for the quest for to
find a language partner is also
important because I think that nothing
nobody has really ever learned a
language by totally by themselves just
with books what happens is that they
have to interact with human beings and
when you interact with human beings
that's that's the moment when your
language skills actually take off you
know people go to a foreign country the
reason why a lot of them even if not all
of them speak a language wellas because
they were forced in a way since they
live in an environment they're forced to
speak the language on a daily basis so
if you don't have the chance to to live
in a foreign country you still have the
internet the Internet is a treasure
trove it's it's absolutely amazing what
you can do with the internet so what you
should do is go to some language sites
where you can find language partners a
couple of names come to mind for example
share talk is very famous as well as
conversation exchange calm and you can
actually select the you know male female
age target language native tongue so
foreign exchange and then and then you
just send an email a message and you say
hey you know I'm Luca I I want to learn
this language I'm a beginner
intermediate I would really like to talk
to you and then you it's very easy
because a lot of people actually do
reply and then you just have people
start having conversations on skype but
once again it is important to know how
to have conversations it's not for the
sake of language learning alright okay
so to wrap this up so in order to start
learning a language from scratch three
things are important first of all to
identify a textbook or a language series
that yeah that is suitable for you yeah
my question is how do I know that
because I'm for instance I'm an absolute
beginner right in language how do I know
that this particular textbook is to
write one for me mhm
there's a couple of things for example
as I said before the very first aspect
is the visual aspect if I don't like
if I don't like a book visually and that
happens obviously I'm not willing to use
it first
second second for me you know it's
important that the the book for example
it has to have a bilingual version of it
has to have your target language as well
as your native tongue or another
language doesn't have to be your native
tongue it can be also it can also be for
example a language that I know quite
well I've learned quite a few languages
through French and English because there
was no version anytime so this is one
the other the other important thing and
then for me it's important that the book
is not to charge with overloaded with
grammar with grammar meaning that to me
it's important to have some grammar
notes along the way along the path but
it doesn't have to hinge on grammar it
has to be on communication and
conversation third the fourth it's
important to have some kind of phonetics
in it meaning that for example
ASIMO which is one of the series that
lot like the best has some explanations
for example they add the stress the
stress - stress patterns two sentences
stress patterns are for those who
doesn't know for those who don't know
what is what it what stress means is
that they some words in every language
especially in English French Italian
they're stressed in a way because they
convey more information if I say for
example say Italy is a great country you
will have Italy is a great country yeah
you will have Italy and country that are
higher in pitch they're stressed because
they are the important elements of the
sentence so it's not just the stress and
the main stress of words but also the
the stressed syllables within words
because every word in English and French
in Italian they have some parts of the
words that are stressed you know they
have an x and y axis and folsom on
certain syllables and a simal provides
that as well as other features so
another very important thing for me
because I do care about pronunciation in
intonation is the idea that they give
you the tools to figure out the phonetic
patterns of a language or
and and possibly even vocabulary but I
don't I don't like we can learn this but
there's a lot of people like them so if
it also has vocabulary lists that's that
that's a plus for a lot of people for me
it's okay and there's another thing that
I wanted to add acid mo has an amazing
feature that it's not much discussed
that much together with the main
dialogue
you also have an exercise after the
dialogue in which they assemble the
words the pieces together in a different
way than the the main dialogue so you
learned some words within the context of
a dialogue of a conversation and then
you can actually see how these words are
used in different contexts and different
sentences and this is quite important
because it relates to what I was saying
before it's all about it's not so much
as learning words pretty important but
also how to assemble them together which
is one of the main features to build a
so called the so called language core
okay got it all right let's move on to
the next question um learning a language
will especially as learning a language
in the beginning takes a lot of time
right and I think most of the people
they fail in maintaining a daily
language routine and one of your core
principles that you preach so this big
is to learn the language or foreign
language every single day right so how
can people do that right how can people
learn the language every single day or
maintain a language learning routine if
they're a full-time if you're working
full time or if you're studying
full-time and there are also other
things in life that's just doing sports
meaning friends and so forth how how can
we tack language learning into that
crowded schedule well I would say that
you know modern times have given us
beautiful things for example the
internet but they have also given us the
curse of a life that is in constant we
are constantly in a hurry you know yes
life is so much faster than before well
I would say first I would say that
no matter what method you what method to
use because the method is important but
there are some cognitive principles that
are extremely important the first first
and foremost I would say that the most
important principle is stick to your
routine every single day now as you said
before this is might sound a little bit
trite but learning every day gives us
the possibility of feeding our own
brains now the problem is as you said
before that a lot of people don't stick
to it because they don't have the time
now when you learn a foreign language
first you have to ask yourself and when
it this is all it has to do with
motivation routine it's all entangled
it's all one thing first ask yourself a
very important question why am i
learning this language if you start with
a kind of feeble motivation if your
motivation is not as strong and your
your motifs your the your goals are kind
of fuzzy and and vague then within 3-4
weeks even if you start with a lot of
energy it will wane with time very
quickly and I think that happened to
apply it a lot of us and in general to
language learners right another very
important thing so first ask yourself
the right questions why am i learning
this language then you have to keep
recalling keep telling yourself why
you're learning that language
imagine that with just 30 or 40 minutes
a day when you can accomplish you can
actually learn an ability acquire an
ability that is going to enable you to
communicate with thousands and thousands
of people around the world for example
right now when I think about learning
Japanese sometimes I struggle sometimes
to tell myself gosh this language is
difficult but the idea of you know the
idea of going to Japan and the idea of
talking to people - millions - millions
of people millions of people who speak a
completely different language and
sometimes and most of the time I would
say they didn't even speak English the
mind boggling possibility of
communicating with somebody cannot speak
any other language is just very
motivating you know right another thing
so so asking yourself the right
questions at the beginning and then
yourself every single day even if it's
at the bat in the back of your mind that
you're doing something that is going to
change your life and make and enrich it
and make it much better it is a huge
motivation booster okay now going back
to to the question that you asked me how
do you do it how do you establish your
team well there are a few things to say
first as I said before start with the
right mindset when we talk about when
people say I don't have the time just
rephrase it and try to say I don't make
of the time and that would change
completely that would completely change
the perspective because you say I don't
make the time it's not that we don't
have the time it's that we make poor use
of it the reality is that every single
day Stefan you me and everybody else
they do some things during the day that
they like you know working out go
jogging
I don't know watching a movie watching a
YouTube video whatever so we actually do
make the time to do some things that we
like no matter what happens to us even
if you have a family and you know it's a
pretty busy life you have your wife you
have your kids etc etc reality is that
we can actually make the time when we're
talking about language learning routine
we're not talking about four hours
language geeks study how call the
language geeks which is not an insult by
the way is about is they can study for
eight hours you know for a four or five
hours because they have the time because
they make the time but a normal person
who's interested in one language they're
not signing 3,000 languages but just one
can actually find 15 30 45 minutes it's
not that it's not such an crazy amount
of time what else will suggest is if you
think about it if you have 30 minutes a
day 30 40 45 minutes a day don't just
study don't just learn a language for 45
minutes a day but divide it into blocks
you wake up in the morning let's suppose
that you wake up in the morning at 6:30
okay if you're an early person or if you
have to work now just try to start 52 to
wake up 15 minutes before 15-minute
minutes earlier and then you for 15
minutes you study something
fifteen minutes in you might say you
might retort it's not a long time but in
15 minutes if you stayed focused you can
actually learn a lot because according
to scientific research small chunks of
you know when you tackle a piece of
information if you if that piece of
information is not very big like for
example reading a book you can simply
read an article your attention span as
well as your concentration is very high
and you tend to retain things much
better so if you have 30 minutes a day
or 45 minutes a day divided into chunks
50 minutes in the morning you wake up a
little bit earlier 15 minutes in the
afternoon remember that even if you work
you have lunch break and lunch break
actually some of my students do that for
example a lawyer he's a lawyer and he
does that all the time say okay lunch
break
I'm gonna study him cuddle or with Luca
you know and it's one hour so imagine
that if you have 15 minutes you can take
in your lunch break you can not only
read an article for example this is
called extensive reading read an
interesting article or you know stick
your language routine when you start
learning a language but you can also eat
which is quite important for the
following in a day okay awesome
so so in terms of learning learning on a
daily basis it's not like learning every
day three or four hours a day because
it's not sustainable right you know long
long run it's really to start small
right for instance
start with 15 minutes a day right and
make it a habit I think that's really
important right so like brushing your
teeth every day in the morning and every
day and every night before sleeping
we're not thinking about it anymore
right the same the same kind of habit
the same kind of mechanism should should
be developed when it comes to learning
and language every single day and it's
really important not to overwhelm
yourself right away yes and yeah
absolutely and there's one more thing
that I forgot is that you not only
divide you know this 45 minute block in
multiple chunks but he also divided
according to the amount of energy that
it requires let's see now when we talk
about language learning
we have writing speaking listening and
reading if you wake up and you are a
morning person and you are fresh in the
morning just try to tackle activities
that require a little bit more of energy
for example producing like speaking and
writing obviously if you don't have any
anybody to talk to you can simply talk
to the microphone of your iPhone and you
can create a small recording short
recording that you can send to a native
speaker so it's not actually true that
we have to have another person to talk
to if you want to talk if you want to
produce something or write write a text
or whatever alright while you can listen
and read when when you're tied for
example you come back from work and
you're pretty tired you don't want to
speak create speeches or writing
whatever you can simply listen and read
which are actually much easier sometimes
than just speaking and writing so it's
not just about dividing into smaller
chunks because it helps your memory
retention as well as attention span is
better etc but you know also have to
decide what kind of schedule want to
stick to and you try to allocate some
time to in the morning or when you're
fresh you you dedicate some time to
activities that require more energy and
then it does quite important and that's
what I do for example with my
bi-directional technique when I have to
translate back so when I translate into
Italian that's kind of easy so I can do
it when I'm tired but what I have to
translate into the target language in
order to absorb it it requires more
energy and concentration and I tend to
do it in the morning before going to
work or before and doing anything
because it's easier alright okay so to
wrap this up so the main point that Luke
is making is that the energy level
throughout the day is not the same
equally right it's not distributed
equally so for instance I'm also a
morning person and I tend to do the
hardest thing in the morning right the
coast and I'm fresh and focused and then
I'm good to go right so right after
lunch right when my belly is full and
I'm kind of feeling the lunch fatigue I
don't know I'm sending emails and
calling people I'm organizing things
right so mechanic
things that you know to require a lot of
brainpower and then in the end in the
evening then my energy level is going up
again I'm doing again more challenging
work right so I think the less is the
main lesson can draw from that is that
no your know your own by written daily
by written yeah when it's the sweet time
and when it's the downtime during the
day and then allocate those tasks and
especially language learning tests and
divide them ya know yourself what is the
most challenging test and allocate them
appropriately according to your yeah by
rhythm I think that's one way yeah
wonderful Rica